you know
so
first when you're sort of learning you
tend to look at his
hand if you start
it's difficult but you have to try to
stop
yourself when they same in the
headlights I do that you see I get I
stop a b and then I go there and I put
it into another mode 's got to look
after their you know I'm going to have
fun but I've also got to care for it
okay they have to look after theirself
they're a little bit s like behind and
they're not active and they're going to
get the old tweak that's going to hurt
them so we have to work
together you don't have to do it hard
you can do it
smoothly soft
you want to put hard on they good then
you start to both enjoy it because he'll
go home thinking some good chemist night
and then he'll also think well I had a
few bad ones that then you can work on
that afterwards yeah this is off the mat
working out when you're on the mat you
have to be
100% connected okay please enjoy
yourself but be careful of others around